biggest reason I push kids to do what  they want versus what their parents want  when you're 60 and they're 80 and you  lived your life based on what they  wanted and now you resent them it gets  real ugly real fast I would rather you  have the pain for the next five or six  years of fighting and then have one of  two things happen which I think both are  amazing number one you were right you  were right and you are in an amazing  fashion designer not an engineer and you  built a real company and your parents  are going to be very very proud or you  were wrong you suck at Fashion Design  nobody liked it but at least for  yourself you never have to live the rest  of your life asking yourself what if you  win both ways regret is scary  resentment is very scary